I feel like the only appropriate way to describe the tiredness
from being a single mom is, like,
I'm tired to the depths of my soul.
Like, I am tired in every little box you can think of,
of tiredness. I am at the max capacity of all of them,
you know?
And the thing about loving your children is that it, like,
it's the deepest love, so it feels like it fills every box as well.
And so there's, like,
so much hurt with that love,
you know? Like,
you know how much hurt they're gonna go through because they have to.
Like, that's just life.
Somebody's gonna talk shit about you and it's gonna hurt your feelings,
but you don't want that to happen cause it's your baby.
Like Fucking Colin Farrell.
I want the world to be nice to my son.
Yeah. And then
I bet you think back
of all the times that you used a word inappropriately
or looked at somebody and laughed or something,
you know,
when my daughter was born with down syndrome,
I was like,
every time I had ever seen someone use the R word,
you know? So
motherhood is like, it.
It's like, max capacity for everything.
It is the max capacity of, like,
love for my children and every depth of love,
but that includes all the darkness that love has,
the fear and the worry and the.
Anyway, it's my daughter's birthday, so I'm hauling my feels.